i didn't know what had happened in the
documentary i was shocked because i went
through the exact same thing
and it made me feel so much closer to
you
i love that you are out there advocating
channeling your inner l woods
in washington tell me about that i was
so on that journey thank you i
it was the most empowering and proudest
of my of my life to be on capitol hill
and speaking about something that you
know
caused me so much pain and trauma but
the fact that i can really turn that
pain into a purpose
and make such a difference and already
have changed laws in seven states and
now
working with representative khanna and
senator merkley on the accountability
for congregate care act and next we're
going to be taking it to a federal level
to push it to all 50 states so the abuse
that happened to myself and so many
others will be illegal today
and
i i i love the resilience too what is
your advice to people to making all of
that your strengths
i would say to anyone who's been through
trauma
just to speak about it and let it out
and i really believe the truth will set
you free
and
just for me this is something i
i feel like these places they really
instill that in the children they want
them to feel ashamed they want everyone
to say to them no one's ever going to
believe you because they don't want to
be caught for what they've done to these
people
so my advice is to
share your truth tell someone hold these
people people accountable and tell your
story and others are not going to feel
alone and it's going to help make a
difference god you are going to help so
many people with this
you are going to set them free you are
going to empower them that will actually
matriculate into them helping other
people it has a domino effect
bravo on everything
[Applause]
[Music]
okay i just learned about your painting
yes tell me everything well i've been
i've loved art my whole life my
grandmother taught me how to paint and
i've just during quarantine it was
finally when i wasn't traveling i wasn't
running around you know everywhere i was
at home and i made a whole art room and
i was painting and doing a lot of things
for charity and then now doing digital
art and
it's just been incredible
we just are doing a new one right now
which is going to be about this topic
about turning your pain into purpose i
i love doing art i love painting i love
all drawing just
it's something that i really enjoy but i
love digital or even more i've been
learning
how to make digital art and there's a
lot that goes into it and it's just i
love how you can make it 3d and movement
and use sound and it's just
the future of art it's so much fun and
the fact that this anyone with the
talent can put their art online and
for the rest of time they will always
get commission on on every sale and in
the traditional art world that was never
possible before it would just be on the
first sale and then they'd never see
anything again and then you're a dj
which i love so much because i'm such a
music nut and um
you you give me hope for myself and
anyone
that what i try to do with this show or
what i try to have as a north star in
life is that we are all not one thing we
are such multi-faceted creatures and
you're that living example thank you
[Applause]
[Music]